première compétition cycliste post
qu'ovide était attendue de tous dans un
premier temps 58 coureurs étaient au
départ et les tout meilleurs du
département où il conduit à la paix de
l'extension club organisateur au baisser
du drapeau un homme prend le large mais
quelle stanislas du gist et 231 de la
martinique il croise les cartes tout
seul raconte à presque une minute avance
dans le peloton
nicolas dumont reste vigilant et caen
qui lie analj coéquipiers de stanislas
attaque
il prend sa roue on est alors à l'appel
du septième tour au début du sixième
tour
les deux hommes reviennent sur stanislas
le trio reste groupé jusqu'à l'arrivée
où cette année ça serait pas détruite de
vote du mont et hal gill à 7 intègre un
test c'était vraiment pouvoir dans
quelles conditions qu'on était après
tout ça de moi de ton arrière de votre
coureur comme je dis ça fait plaisir
parce qu'on peut vraiment se tester on
attend c'est le bluff et s'est passé on
se retrouvait à deux devant on fait un
toit c'est vraiment de bon augure pour
la suite
dimanche prochain l'exception propose le
même type de course cette fois ce sera
la route de calvaire